in Seattle I'm sorry he was into me from
the second I got it why did she rule my
daughter away from me moving was Sam's
idea fine after his last thing last
night he would have said no so I didn't
we have unconfirmed reports of a large
seismic event off the California coast
with reports of power outages across the
United States why did you come back I
didn't know how else to know have you
talked to Sam we got disconnected what's
the last thing she said she sounded
scared
[Music]
that's not all we know well we have no
idea what's happening yeah we got
twenty-twos doing flybys she's alone
2,000 miles away so you only have one
question for you are down the government
is silent we don't know who is causing
this there's a lot to be afraid of out
there a lot of real danger should have
told me that she had a gun no assuming
that you've never fired a firearm
I've seen four game simulations events
just like this you're designed to erase
rational behavior with what appears to
be a singular incident you ever seen
clouds like that before
you just drive up at this
[Music]
I can't stay like this forever do you
really think that
you
you